[Música]
y en directo hablamos de Colombia y los
nuevos hallazgos en la búsqueda de los
niños que desaparecieron en la selva del
guaviare tras un accidente aéreo un mes
después de que ocurrieron los hechos las
autoridades mantienen la esperanza
nuestro periodista Judith Muñoz con los
detalles
en las últimas horas las fuerzas armadas
han iniciado la que consideran podría
ser la prueba final en la búsqueda de
los niños han llevado hasta la espesa
selva reflectores sonido y perifoneo
terrestre estos tienen potencia para
notarse entre 500 metros y un kilómetro
y esperan que sea una forma de atraer a
los niños el lunes el general al mando
de la operación informó que creían haber
estado a 100 m de los niños tras
encontrar una huella fresca de la mayor
de las niñas de 13 años en las semanas
anteriores habían encontrado un pañal
unas tijeras e incluso frutas mordidas
el grupo de búsqueda formado por
militares e indígenas ha recorrido más
de 1.250 kilómetros que es como ir de
Bogotá hasta quito en Ecuador y retornar
hasta la frontera entre Colombia y
Ecuador el perímetro ahora se reduce a
una área de 30 kilómetros cuadrados
desde la comandancia de la misión
descartan que pudieran estar en manos de
un grupo armado ilegal basado en las
selvas de Colombia uno de los temores
entre la población en la semana pasada
estuvimos en la base de operaciones en
la frontera con la selva con militares e
indígenas el caso ha traído mucha
atención en Colombia e
internacionalmente sobre todo después de
que el presidente de Colombia Gustavo
Petro tuitease que habían sido
encontrados dos semanas después del
accidente información que tuvo que
desmentir al día siguiente el lema desde
entonces para el gobierno desplazado en
terreno los militares y los indígenas ha
sido buscarlos hasta encontrarlos de
hecho esta Unión de militares e
indígenas ha llamado la atención puesto
que la relación históricamente ha sido
de desconfianza y ahora se está poniendo
en valor los conocimientos de la selva
de indígenas de comunidades muy alejadas
así como sus creencias culturales en la
búsqueda